An Internet worm first scans for vulnerable
hosts, then infects them, and finally, typically takes
steps to remain undetectable. A worm does
not necessarily need to patch the host vulnerability,
although some Internet worms have been known
to do so, to prevent other worms from
subsequently infecting the machine and interfering with the
original worm infection. For example, if a worm
was intending to spread to construct a botnet that launched a particular
attack or was being used by a botmaster for a particular attack, then
whoever had commandeered the machine, probably
wouldn't want other attackers to come in
behind him and also infect the machine and interfere with the planned attacks.